muy buenos días raúl pues en estos
momentos hay más de 80 millones de
personas bajo alerta invernal y han sido
cancelados cerca de 3.200 vuelos en esa
poderosa tormenta invernal que llega
cargada de nieve lluvia helada y hielo
que es precisamente algo que preocupa
mucho por esa dificultad ese peligro que
puede haber en las carreteras hay más de
200 mil personas que se han quedado sin
suministro eléctrico en este en esta
tormenta invernal que afecta a cerca de
2.000 kilómetros desde misisipí hasta
maine los gobernadores de georgia y
carolina del norte han decretado el
estado de emergencia por la situación
que allí se está viviendo y en esta
último en carolina del norte se han
recogido en algunas zonas hasta 25
centímetros de nieve hay que lamentar la
muerte de dos personas por un accidente
en carretera en florida ha habido varios
tornados que han provocado distintos
destrozos pero afortunadamente no hay
que lamentar ningún fallecido en esta
tormenta se dirige desde anoche al
noreste y en su camino pasa por el
estado de nueva york cuál es la
situación allí
sin nueva york se encuentra en el camino
como dices de esa tormenta que está
subiendo hacia canadá aquí desde anoche
también se pidió mucha precaución en la
carretera porque en algunas zonas del
estado se esperan inundaciones y
acumulación de nieve se ha decretado la
alerta por tormenta y bernal también en
todo el estado y en algunas zonas
incluso se ha establecido el código azul
que eso significa que hay frío extremo
por lo tanto se está muy pendiente de
aquellas personas que viven en la calles
en cuanto al estado de nueva york aquí
en la ciudad anoche tuvimos varias horas
durante varias horas estuvo nevando pero
las temperaturas han ido poco a poco
subiendo como veis ahora mismo la imagen
ya no es blanca como la que veíamos ayer
ahora mismo lo que preocupa mucho son
las fuertes precipitaciones y los
vientos huracanados pero eso se pide a
la población mucha precaución aunque
hemos de decir que hoy la mayoría de
escuelas y empresas están cerradas
celebrando el día de martin luther king